hey guys chasity here at the GameSpot
co-op stage I'm here with my friend two
more and we're gonna talk about
spider-man Marvel's spider-man coming
from insomniac games we have Brian in
Tahar the creative director of insomniac
games here thank you for coming
I've applause I like it so excited we
have to talk about spider-man
I love spider-man tomorrow what do you
want to know about me I'm a big
spider-man fan too and I guess it's it's
kind of obvious why you'd have a
spider-man around now it's quite a new
spider-man game but why do you think
this is a good time to return to
spider-man there's been a kind of lack
of spider-man games recently yeah I mean
I just think it goes comes down to right
time right hopefully the hopefully
developer right partners and with Marvel
and Sony and uh you know I think we made
something overdrive I remember actually
reading a really early sunset overdrive
review and someone actually wrote it
something could be great at making a
spider-man game and I actually copy and
pasted that and sent it to so many
saying see we should do this and you
know just in terms of us as its
developer were you know sunset overdrive
we had a lot of fun with traversal right
a character that traverses a lot around
his sense of humor and his gadgetry fits
in Sonic really well and just as being a
Marvel fan my whole life and being a big
spider-man fan it just it was a perfect
fit
yeah and obviously you come you bring in
a spider-man game to market at a time
when superhero the superhero genre is
shifted quiet
yeah significantly now there's games out
there that like Batman for example they
have changed the perception of superhero
games so you can't get away with a half
a superhero game anymore no I mean
something that you think about and yeah
I have a lot less hair in my head
because of that that exact thing I mean
first of all a huge fan of Arkham
obviously and um but just if you even
look at the movies right like what
Marvel is doing on the movie front or
their TV shows the level of quality the
quality bars raised so high and I think
you know you go back to your question
why now well the need for a spider-man
game that is you know that people really
really going to love that's what we want
to do I mean we just we feel like it's
too right it's really the right time and
we like we hopefully can deliver it all
right I remember the sheer joy with the
reveal last year and then I was I felt
equally excited seeing
trailer this year yeah I mean and that's
all game play like I mean that's that's
the mission I mean we bit some parts a
little bit shorter just for time right
but that's an actual mission from the
game the mission start to the mission
end so um I think some people were kind
of confused this is a trailer know it
this is just we captured a mission so
it's I mean we're playing it we've been
playing it live at the that's Estonia
booth both behind closed doors not that
big theater so for those that are not at
e3 and have not had the chance to play
let's dive a little bit into this
trailer so let's talk about the
mechanics so you see webslinger what are
what's new yeah so I think I mean I
think of three big things this is really
a demo we put together that really shows
why was our Spider Man like and what
first of all starts with combat what
you're seeing now in this idea of he's
not just a bruiser actually he's not a
bruiser he's more of an acrobatic
improviser right he's combining webs
ground combat air combat in fiber action
stealth and even gadgetry to give you a
lot of player choice and what you're
seeing people play the game at
Dominick's playing it this week they're
changing up the strategy a lot
second thing is traversal you got we
have to nail traversal
that's signature of the character but we
also want to expand his moveset add
elements like parkour and in this demo
later on you'll see him running through
an office building all those parkour
elements applied to when you're in the
open world as well whether you're on the
on the street love or even on the
rooftops and then lastly for us it's the
spectacle moment so it's like big
blockbuster moans you would see like in
our epic Marvel movie right and bring
those to life and let you being a beat
make you part of it it really nailing
that so those are the three big elements
when it comes to the spider-man side of
this experience he took a little bit
more about the swinging because the
trailer was quite focused on the action
element of it we saw a lot of combat we
saw him kind of transitioning through
these set-piece moments but we didn't
get as much swinging as we expect so the
portion after the crane til when you
actually actually get thrown into the
building that's all gameplay traversal
we're just happened to be chasing a
helicopter right but you can do that
same sequence I mean you could traverse
that same area in the open world so that
that for us it's about fluidity flow
freedom style but at the same time
expanding his moveset and you know in
speed as well um so that's just this is
a short section of the game
it's a very story-based mission the
whole island Manhattan's going to be
available you from day one so one of the
and also just clarify the webs actually
do catch the buildings that's alright I
was going to ask about ads attached to
buildings I promise you so obviously
everyone brings up spider-man 2 as the
lot about it this week
I actually unpopular opinion I love the
swinging from the amazing spider-man
game ok I think that is probably what my
favorite swinging mechanic just cause
the way you jump up a building and the
camera swoops in behind you it gives you
this exhilarating feeling yeah we we you
know I mean we are still in development
so we're gonna be doing more things with
our camera kind of cell-cell the sense
of speed yeah slow and cinematic kind of
feel as you swing your eyes I guess I
was going to ask like what have you what
have you been looking at in terms of
games and other spider-man everything I
mean obviously you know I I go back as
far as I is spider-man 1 on the P on the
ps1 you know whenever soft that game
that did have open-world but it
definitely made you feel like spider-man
and then obviously spider-man 2 and then
everything has come with it but not just
looking at spider-man games but
open-world games in general obviously
looking at our home and all you know how
they handled you know dealing with a
iconic character like Batman we look at
pretty much everything I mean we're look
it's a pretty beefy game and we
obviously want to see what other people
have done but add our own insomniac
flavor anyway in terms of the combat
people are going to look at it and from
a surface level it looks very much like
Batman combat but you've clearly done
some a little a little more tweaking to
it so can you talk a bit about how it
kind of differentiate I think you know I
mean not to go too much in comparison
but I think one thing we really want to
capitalize on is what makes spider-man
unique you know he's much more acrobatic
um he you know he has a we have this
idea of feeling like a ping pong around
a different environment that's what
that's what we want to sell that you
know I don't want to see him walking I
want you know we have a button dedicated
to web striking because we want you to
be really moving around the environment
pretty well like you can see people when
they play they actually jump off enemies
on to another one
um combining that with webs all the
environment reaction we have really I
think it's again make you feel like you
can play how you want and depending on
what to choice you're in the environment
the the enemies really be able to
improvise and change your
Yeah right I think it's time to get a
bit nerdy yep all right so what ya going
Peter Parker in here but we also see
miles at the end right yeah houses in
the game okay what's the deal was his
role of what oh I can't go too much into
it but I think with miles is I'd be
saying three things really one is we
talking about it being unique spider-man
universe um miles as part of that
journey um you know it's not some weird
into been general portal that miles came
through and now he's there he just isn't
the same world as Peter l2 is this is
very much a Peter Parker story yet be
having Myles there allows us to kind of
tell a different a different a different
side of Peter show different side of
Peter and third is I just love the
character I think he's fantastic and I
wanted him to expose him to more people
right obviously Myles is known for also
being spider-man is there only one
spider-man in this game we'll talk more
let my okay okay then you know this is
our first extended version they look at
the game we'll have more talk this is
really whether it's the combat traversal
the world and particularly the story
we're really scratching surface you know
I was actually a couple weeks ago
talking to some people about the whole
story and I went back to our lead writer
John Paquette and I said man this is a
pretty big game and I think what you're
seeing is I'm just scratching your
surface and you know we talk a lot about
what makes a great spider-man story and
for you know Marvel's all that story and
when Peters world of spider-man's world
collide that's when the magic happens
and we're going to see that not just
with Martin Lee who works at feast and
on may works there as well
but multiple characters and situations
in our ganna can we talk about the
villain here Martin Lee yeah Lee is a
relative newcomer to the spider-man
universe which I would say represents
kind of we have a group of familiar
villains like kingpin which you also saw
on this but you also see Martin Lee a
newcomer and what we like going back to
those worlds colliding Martin Lee allows
us to kind of see that whereas because
Aunt May works at feast the feast or
where Martin lanes established them um
but at the same time from a gameplay
standpoint the inner demons with their
abilities the the negative weapons the
you know such as the big guy with those
negative energy
max it allows us to add a different type
of strategy to our combat account right
there's also eagle-eyed viewers will
notice Yuri Watanabe is mentioned there
yeah so she's his police contact in this
game but another character we wanted to
we wanted to highlight and you know you
know I didn't spider-man story his
relationship with the city is Right
complex yeah some people think he's a
hero some people love him some people
think he's a vigilante some people home
a menace right um Yuri happens to be one
of those people that believes the city
could use someone like spider-man so she
goes our way to keep him in the loop I
mean spider-man's relationship with the
sea is complex but his relationship with
Yuri those are complex because obviously
Yuri has an alter ego she's great so is
that something that you're kind of
thinking about as well we have a lot
she's great okay so are you gonna try
and kind of build in you don't have to
mention specifics but like there's so
many different complex characters within
the widest part and universe are you
kind of bringing those in yeah I mean I
think that the great thing is he does
have a huge cast of characters not just
the villains but also maybe characters
like a Yuri Watanabe right and I think
that we're gonna lean on having a lot of
Marvel characters that are part of our
main universe in this game even in let's
say less role less not as well known
roles okay cool nice so let's talk about
Peters backstory in this game know he's
been spider-man for eight years right
did your research that's impressive
right yeah so what else do we need to
know about so he's um he's 23
he's just graduated college and he's
working as a scientist so um it's not
the Daily Bugle in this game for him
he's now we want to really want to push
the you know Peter's a really smart guy
you know he's a really you know and
whether that's the design of his shoe is
gadgets we really want to lean into that
side you know this scientist aspect of
him right and his supporting kind of
family Mary Jane any of those guys
showing up Gwen Stacy I talked about
Aunt May all may see only one it's a
pretty big cast
Jameson pretty big cast okay cool that's
fine that's fine but yeah I'm kind of
like interested more in the way you're
kind of building the city and what
at ground level that's the thing that
yeah it's difficult to do you get the
you know you have space in the sky but
when you reach the ground and a lot of
spider-man games it can feel quite empty
so you're approaching that yeah so it ah
so we frost New York City's a character
within itself right we it was very
important that it felt like a living
breathing city and you can't have a
living breathing city without people
right vehicles and interactions and
that's all there you know I'm not going
super details of the of the open-world
but I will tell you that this is a
living breathing city that no spider-man
is there and reacts to spider-man
ok and in terms of like your progression
through this story is it you know it's
an open world but is it similar in terms
of you have missions and side quests and
that kind of thing over here I would say
we're not like I said I'm not going to
huge it's a structure the game but there
is a there's a mainline story and there
are other activities to do in the world
kind of cool I want to ask about the
white spider ok so tell me about that I
will tell you I can't I can't tell you
why the white spider is there like a
story reason but I can't tell you like
the white spider Frost kind of is
signifies the suit design actually
signifies our philosophy of the game
when you look at that character you know
that Spider Man right it's got the red
it's got the blue it's got the Basques
but you look at the big white spider it
looks a little different right you know
that's insomniac spider-man that's our
as our universe but the same time we
didn't want to do it just for shock
value or to get some hate email whatever
I've got um there's a very specific
story reason for it and you'll
understand that reason when you play the
game everything we try to everything we
do we try to have a story reason for it
well living a moment where something bad
happens and he gets all angsty and
colors in black with because if that
happens I'll be very upset now do you
like do you like the suit I like this
suit ok I like it I like the eyes can
you talk about the eyes oh yeah so one I
mean I got thats a great question um I
actually have got that question a lot um
we won the challenge with you know as
you can tell it's a very you know it's a
real realistic looking game right and
when you have a character whose face is
covered it's hard to get emotion
expressiveness but you know we look you
know you look at the comics his eyes are
very expressive right and while they may
not be as dramatic as you know some of
the comics do we wanted to use the the
shape of the eyes to kind of communicate
how he's feeling give him some
expression so you know that's really our
animators our riggers our character
artists really gave us that flexibility
of able to manipulate his eyes
do you have more expressive more
expressive character and it seems to
work I mean you look at a Deadpool movie
and yeah one of the things that yeah
right other thing is I saw it in Civil
War right and I was like who are you
doing this already we're gonna get ready
um and um but it just shows we're on the
same page which to me as we're doing
something right so the game is coming in
2018 2018 well you can say that's all
you can say I got to get it right yeah
the most important thing about this game
is we know how important it is to fans
we know how important is to us cuz we
are fans and we just want to spend the
time to get it right because they
deserve it
alright Brian thank you so much for
coming having me give it kind of a box
of Ryan thanks everyone looking forward
to spider-man thank you yeah we're gonna
bring up two of our friends that you
know well we've got Mike McCarty and
Peter Brown and we're gonna round up the
show because this is the last panel yeah
three 2017 cos we made it yeah we made
it can't believe it's all right let's
let's round it up like right what do you
think of e3 2017
I loved it cuz Nintendo gave me a great
show and that's what I was hoping for I
got a lot of Metroid stuff but otherwise
a lot of publishers had great things it
was a good year all right Mike yeah
Nintendo was awesome
but I also was kind of like pleasantly
surprised by it like Ubisoft and stuff
like that and Microsoft uh you know I
think Microsoft in the last couple years
kind of struggled to present itself well
I at the conference but they did really
well this year um III in general was
really fun tiring but it's cool to see
like the public this year like a key I
don't yeah how does that compare how
many III have you been - this is my
second full time I started like right
before you know I start yeah this is my
second e3 game spot but um I wasn't down
here as much as I would have liked to be
because I was doing the state upstairs
of people but yeah that's definitely a
little more crowded but lines were
longer but at least I do play I agree
it's good to see like the consumers and
people who love games about I guess
people who work here we often like aha
we got to get through these people but
like when you're down here you see the
excitement you see people you know
really looking forward to seeing games
and then you see the developers in line
seeing those people in line and noticing
that you
okay it's kind of like it builds a good
atmosphere it's good I think it's been a
good III Microsoft did really really
well I felt like they had a lot of games
and they've like Mike said they've
struggled in the past so they came out
really strong Ubisoft was a big surprise
they gave us a rabbit scam and Mario
game and despite the fact that everyone
was like yeah everyone hated the idea of
it and then they came out and were like
Harry is and everyone went damn now I'm
gonna play this and I played it and it
was great and I really enjoyed it yeah
and no rabbit rabbits good Dragon Ball Z
Dragon Ball v Dragonball Z game oh my
god oh my god oh my god I'm so excited
about that yeah and Mario marry looks
great how can you not be excited about
throwing your hat on a bullet bill and
then flying guys biggest surprises for
you
Metroid was a huge surprise yeah but I
think you know Bethesda was really
strong with their 2017 lineup and I'm
you know surprised and delighted to see
evil within - and Wolfenstein - both
coming out this year like yeah awesome
yeah Beyond Good and Evil 2 was a
surprise to me I actually don't I'm not
excited for it and I don't have that
much of an attachment to the first game
I'm just more surprised that they
actually showed it after like clamoring
for it for so long but at least people
who wanted it got it you know about
biggest disappointments yeah I think I
could I wanted to see the Last of Us to
Sony's press conference was quite Ike
expected why what they gave and it was
which is a very shame because they
usually come out and throw out something
that no one expected and we're like wow
that was unbelievable and although it
wasn't a bad press conference there were
no major surprises and the fact that
they didn't have the loss of us - was
kind of disappointing I expect we'll see
that PlayStation experience and we'll
have more surprises there
but I wanted a bit more from Sony even
though I did ultimately enjoy what they
showed us what about you guys biggest
disappointments I was really hoping for
Microsoft to show off some first party
stuff that was going to be exciting
forces good I have no doubt that game
would be good but it's always expected
right so Microsoft despite having a
great console to show off didn't have
the games I was looking for honestly
Mike yeah last month - and the lack of
first party on Microsoft I would also
say we robbing my biggest but I also
kind of want to see something farther in
the future for
Fez de just because I'm such a big fan
of all the things they publish it was
nice to see so many like games that are
soon to be released announced and
showing off but I would kind of like the
tease of something in 2018 but I guess
that's how it went
we forgot anthem anthem was a gag
surprise that and that was a TS press
conference and it looks really really
cool it's like Iron Man with mixed with
destiny yeah which I am all in for and
yeah we could see quite a bit of that
this year so yeah that's cool that's an
Xbox Scorpio how about that I'm I'm
tentatively excited for it I don't have
a 4k TV and that's one Xbox one X I'm
not sure about that name yet I keep
calling it a Scorpio and I call it
Scorpio to Phil Spencer here at it too
on that he did it I said I said it and I
felt bad then he did it and I was like
well I don't need to feel bad anyway
yeah but I it's a for Katie no machine I
don't have a 4k TV and it doesn't have
many first party titles I expect I will
be an idiot and be bad with my money and
buy one eventually with a 4k TV but
right now I'm cool I'm all right
it will make games on a 1080p screen
look better by by the what you know
means of downsampling and having to you
know do different anti-aliasing
techniques but I'm with you you need
that 4k TV for it but the console looks
great yeah oh yeah yeah Mike you're
getting an Xbox one X I don't know if
I'll get it right away like I said I'd
like to see more of the first-party
exclusives although Ori and the
whispering willows know welcome to PC
love the wilt now yeah yeah Windows 10
and whatnot but uh yeah it was pretty
impressed by it i but like I said I'd
like to see more first party stuff on it
yeah we get to do it the other big game
I think I wanted to see that gonna show
up with some sort of fallout or a Skyrim
follow up we got notify Skyrim and
fallout in VR yep they're back here I
need new not the same old one yeah
Skyrim is still around Skyrim is still a
threat you were on reddit for that don't
know what Skyrim that would be good I
think Skyrim has been at more press
conferences now than call of G which is
unbelievable like somehow but yeah I'd
like I'd like it if they wrap up the
Skyrim story and move on to something
else now sick of seeing those dragons
and stuff but
we know they're making it I mean that
way they all making it yeah but I just I
wanted a big RPG from Bethesda to kind
of round out their their games for 2018
even if it was further in the future so
that was a bit of a shame but did anyone
get to play Mario Odyssey yeah yeah I
just did like an hour ago and you played
it what a few days ago yeah like last
Sunday yeah really it's fun
good yeah it's great it really really
adapts you know to the traditional 3d
Mario controls into a setting that is
surprising and unusual and damn weird
it's it's so strange but in like a
really great politics Mario does that
that's that that's the biggest thing
about obviously the implications they
introduces to Mario Lauria is
mind-blowing it wasn't is Mario even
sentient or is it the Hat is capi
exactly its have you been controlling
being by the time yeah Mario is a pareo
could be a parasite just and Cappy is
the main life-form yes struggling to
deal with this plumber jumping around
all the time
so yeah I'm excited to play that game
it's it's freaky in some ways but they
haven't revealed too much about how it
all fits together but they have the
Odyssey the spaceship that moves you
around yeah like when we had it on our
stage they were showing off an area
which is really vibrant and and like it
had it was a desert area but there was
loads of ice there yeah it's kind of
like it's confusing and then like if you
skip to new donkey which is like a New
York type area name yeah you don't see
as an excellent name and but it's like
concrete jungle really grey and so I was
worried for a bit it was like oh they
don't have the vibrancy of a Mario game
and then they showed off that stuff and
I was like wow they're all in and they
had the mic was with me when when they
were showing off my and they had the 2d
side-scrolling stuff yep that was
amazing that was really cool that's
really fun I played that toast arena
town that they showed off on our demo
that desert with the ice yeah it's
really fun you go into the pipe and then
you it's almost like a link between
worlds yeah
coming up painting but no but it just
goes you can't throw your cab yeah
reverts to the old-school Mario controls
if you get the Crouch everything but you
can't throw your cap but you also keep
whatever outfit you were wearing in the
3d world so you can have that Safari
outfit but side-scrolling yeah that
part's really fun we were talking about
how it's really good for kind of giving
something testing the skills of a
classic Mario fan so instead of having
all the 3d stuff if you were playing
Mario back in the day you
and play this section of the game and
get a little flavor from the old school
days and like there's one bit where a
bullet bill was in the 2d plane and it
went off the side and just came out in
3d and it was really cool to see it I
was like damn that's cool
yeah anyone gets to play any other
Nintendo games nothing uh I didn't get
to play it but I saw a game coming from
the creative director of the dark Sider
series that will be on switch nice it's
a it's a dungeon crawling game but it
has like J RPG style turn-based battles
and it's got that great sort of like
painterly style that you'd see like the
Darksiders games it's called battle
chasers okay it's a very generic name
but the game is very striking it's equal
to the comic book series that's been
missing for a really long time so Medora
yeah yeah you know he worked at Marvel
and DC yeah yeah and he was kind of
behind the art but before he made
Darksiders he created comic book series
called Belle chases and then he didn't
finish it and for the longest time
people have been begging him to finish
it and he's not done it in the comic
book world by in China in the video game
oh so this is picking up where that
comic book left over so it's got a lot
of like RPG fans coming into it that are
interested in it because of kind of like
the Chrono Trigger cover elements of it
and they artwork and that kind of stuff
but it's also got comic book fans kind
of paying attention to it now it's
really cool I also got to interview you
know the head of monolith soft who's
making Xenoblade Chronicles 2 for the
switch today a couple interesting
revelations he doesn't like to play rpgs
right that's all he makes for living so
he actually plays battlefield 1 more
than anything else which I found super
surprising we started talking about VR
and I asked him okay well you're
impressed by it what things have you
played in it what do you like to spend
your time and in VR and he goes adult
things I was a very candid interview but
uh yeah that guy really didn't eat books
yeah kidding
what'd you say nothing did anyone get to
check out Sorrows battlefront 2 I done
fortunately no that was Rob played a
decent about it one of his favorite
thing from the show I really want to
play it
yeah it really want to be a battle droid
and I want to win as a battle droid I
feel like it'd be really insulting to
lose to a battle droid
it looks it looks really enticing to me
because it's actually more of a shooter
this time around than the first one see
maybe the first one is all like Star
Wars surface
which I like for like five hours well
there's supposed to be an awesome story
mode and the story mode yeah the
progression the multiplayer the actual
deeper shooter mechanics but the story
mode as well as probably the main allure
for me telling from the Imperial side of
things seems really appealing yeah like
a whole new perspective just that you've
never seen before I'm really excited
about that yeah I was gonna say I think
you know like in the GameSpot office
you're one of the like foremost Star
Wars experts I would say like between
you and Rob you must be excited it's
like bridging the gap right Star War to
you know Green returned the Jedi in the
force awakens kind of not bridging the
entire gap but it's a pset between them
yeah that's exciting
I'm really excited about ecology World
War two I prizing Lee I'm did you anyway
sorry I haven't played it know by
interview developer and I saw a bunch of
it I've been doing a lot of research by
and I like the idea of stripping away
some of the more modern you know like
the movement stuff to try and I'm
interested in seeing how that changes
the way Call of Duty fans play the game
they've had so many of these games now
where it's been
if someone's shooting at you leap into
the sky and then climb along a wall and
fire a rocket at their feet or something
like that some really interesting seeing
what happens when you give them a game
where you can't automatically heal your
health you have to you know have someone
come over and help you and you know you
can't sprint for infinite amounts of
time so going online and I'm hoping like
basically I'm hoping that I can finally
play multiplayer again and not
absolutely get stomped by kids behind
you know I've been playing it for
hundreds and hundreds of hours I got the
old-school skills for Call of Duty so
hopefully I can be in a campaign surface
again you guys check out World War 2 you
think no time for the reveal but I'm
excited for it I was telling him like I
wasn't at first just because I played
someone I mean we played so many World
War two shooters and from what they've
shown in the trailers it looks like it's
just more of like a Saving Private Ryan
kind of storyline but the more I think
about it the more I'm like well that
actually wouldn't be bad to see it with
like updated graphics that are better
than called duty to your what's the last
World War 2 shooter I think it's well
yeah Call of Duty 2 followed like that
stuff you go on that but yeah regardless
on that I'll play it I agree
what's your highlight from e3 2017
experiential or not or just something
that happened to you Metroid I tried
coming back yep it's a big deal to me
hmm got two games that represent like
two eras of the series that are both
really great so I that was more than I
could ever ask for you make
sound when you heard about it huh did
you make a sound when you heard about it
yeah well so I saw I saw the Metroid
Prime announcement in like a closed-door
session within 1000 people and I just
wanted to note that right now like
maintain composure it was like oh but
the know the famous returns like that
review that came during the treehouse I
was like not paying attention in the
treehouse because they had finished
their spotlight
I was talking to video editors and I'm
like looking at the TV and it just like
what the hell holy [ __ ] there's another
Metroid like I had so blown away by that
really crappy two minutes left Mike what
was your highlight uh we got to
interview Phil Spencer to kick off our
upstage are upstairs stage there yeah
I'm really tired but yeah he was really
like it went really well he's fun to
talk to but it was also nice to he's
pretty candid cuz yeah he kind of like
grilled him a little bit but yeah he was
a great guy in like really candid and
people seem to be pretty positive in the
comments despite the fact that a lot of
it was like you know you expect the
fanboy kind of stuff but yeah worked out
well Sam yeah similar interviewing of
Phil Spencer I'm glad to see there's a
good Dragonball Z game I run into h3h3
outside while I was going to have a
quick vape which was pretty good showed
everyone that yeah I showed everyone
area yeah ended up on the top of Reddit
so yeah great two things on reddit this
week I know the the Skyrim one did the
other one is a nation thing is just just
between me and him I say it's cool cuz I
got pulled up on stage for my just
stance appointment which I thought was
be private but it was on the stage in
front of everyone and I did just dance
20:18 Jevons for a good deal so I okay
though so that was as my highlight
getting over my fears of dancing in
front of vlog yeah kind of like the
worst way to dance is in front of a toe
program you're afraid of dancing yeah
yeah and learning choreography on the
fly terrifying nice terrifying I dunno
envy you one bit yeah but that was it we
survived we did it 2017 we did it it's
over thank you guys so much for watching
all of our GameSpot coverage keep
watching all of our videos cuz there's
so much you probably missed there's so
much I miss if so but you guys might
have missed so keep it locked
see you GameSpot for all your III 2017
coverage I'm chastity Tam thank you Mike
thank you Peter we'll see you next year